the walking dead is a fan favorite show
and once the most watched cable
television series because of the series
longevity viewers got to watch as many
characters age before their eyes and
after the show's time jump in season 9
many younger characters were completely
recast to reflect their drastic age
changes resulting in some roles that
have had multiple actors judith grimes
was born during the walking dead season
3 when maggie performed an emergency
delivery while the prison in which the
survivors were staying became overrun
with zombies judith's mother laurie died
in childbirth and lori's husband rick
raised judith alongside his son carl a
total of 18 actors many of them twin
infants or babies have played the
character on the show since judith's
first appearance twins chloe and sophia
garcia frizzy played judith as a toddler
as she aged from season six to eight
with kinsley isla dillon taking over the
role as a six-year-old judith in season
8. following rex disappearance in season
9 the story experienced a six year time
jump in which judith aged necessitating
the roles recasting kaylee fleming then
to go for the part and will continue to
play judith in season 11. fleming is no
stranger to fans of genre tv and film
she played a young rae in the last two
star wars movies the force awakens and
the rise of skywalker and she recently
played young sylvie on loki fleming's
introduction as judith is one of the
most memorable in the series aged by
several years judith emerged from the
woods holding rick's gun carrying
michonne's katana and wearing carl's hat
since her big brother carl's death and
rick's disappearance judas has been
raised by michonne and a half brother rj
and she's proven herself as capable of
killing zombies as a more experienced
family members viewers first met
ten-year-old henry in season seven a
member of the kingdom henry was taken
care of by his older brother benjamin he
was murdered by a savior during a supply
run on a mission for revenge henry
insisted on joining carroll in the fight
against the saviors proving himself a
valuable member in the battle against
negan henry who was adopted by ezekiel
and carroll during the season 9 time
jump was also known as prince henry
initially portrayed by maxon lynch henry
became a 17 year old young man seemingly
overnight and matlins took over the role
from his younger brother the lint's
family had a long history with the
walking dead their sister madison lynch
played carol's daughter sofia in seasons
one and two the older henry moved to the
hilltop colony became a blacksmith's
apprentice and fell in love with lydia a
former whisperer whose mother alpha
disowned her after she formed a bond
with daryl dixon and others from the
communities including henry alpha
captured and killed henry by
decapitation as a message to her
daughter and the others marking the end
of the lindsay's appearances on the show
few walking dead characters have been as
beloved as glenrie whose death at the
hands of negan in season six hits fans
hard and served a huge blow to the show
when fans found the scene outrageous
fortunately the character has lived on
through his son with wife maggie outside
of ultrasound images herschel re made
his first appearance on the show in
season 9 as a baby only to age 6 years
after rick's supposed death he's just
perfect he really is maggie and herschel
left hilltop for georgie's group so they
wouldn't be near negan but they're
expected to play a large part in the
upcoming final season during his time on
the show young herschel has been
portrayed by three actors including
peyton lockridge in season 9 and the
most recent actor kian michael spiller
the young boy wears a hat reminiscent of
glenn's from season one and two and he
seems to have a gentle nature just like
his grandfather only time will tell what
the future holds for the son of one of
the show's most popular couples
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one